名前はアンバラッティカラーフロワーダ・スッタという名前なんです
エーワンメー・スタン・エーカン・サマヤン・バガワー・ラージャ・ガヘー・ヴィーラティ・ヴェールワネー・カランダカ・ニワーペー
そちらにお釈迦様と場所を言ってるんですね
この経典はどこで住んでいた時のところかと
ラージャ・ガハという王舎城ですね
そこでヴェールワネー・カランダカ・ニワーペー
チクリン精舎という日本訳でしょうと思いますけど
チクリンのカランダカ・ニワーパ僧院に住んでおられたということ
テーナ・コーパナ・サマエーナ・アーヤスマ・ラーフロ・アンバラッティカヤン・ヴィーラティ
その時 テーナ・コーパナ・サマエーナ・アーヤスマ・ラーフロ
ラーフラというお坊さんが
ラーフラ尊者が アンバラッティカヤン・ヴィーラティ
アンバラッティカというところに住んでいましたと
このアンバラッティカという場所は何なのかと
この注釈書に書いてあるところはこういうところなんですね
ヴェールワネーと言ったら
そこら辺 近所ですね チクリン精舎の近所に
パダーナ・ガル・サンケーペー・ヴィーカ・カーマーナン・ワサナッターヤ
チクリン精舎はお釈迦様と大勢の比丘たち住んでいるところだから
かなり人の出入りがたくさんですね
ですから 一人静かに修行したいと
一人で静かにいたいと思う人々の出家のために
ちょっと近所のところで
ある建物がありましたと
住むための ですから アンバラッティカというのは
ある建物の名前なんですね
ですから そちらにはあまり人は出入りはしない
人を入らないところなんですね
で 別なところに建物がありますと
カン
トコ・ナーマ・ジャータ・カーラトー・パッターヤ・ティッキノーヴァ・ホーティ・エーワ・メーワン・アヤンピ・アーヤスマ・サッタ・ヴァッシカ・サーマナーラ・
カーレー・エーワ・パヴィヴェーカ・ブルーヘー・マーノー・タッタ・ヴィハーシ
で また注釈書の訳なんですけど
トゲというものは 植物に現れるものなんですけど
見たことがあると思いますけど
トゲっていうのは現れた時からかなり鋭いんですね
ゆっくり後で鋭くなるということではなくて
トゲっていうのは出た瞬間から鋭いと
そのように このラーフラ尊者も
サッタ・ヴァッシカ・サーマナーラ・カーレー・エーワ
七歳の沙弥でいた時からもう
パヴィヴェーカ・ブルーヘー・マーノー・タッタ・ヴィハーシ
ものすごく一人で グループから大勢の人々とワイワイと生活することはあまり好きじゃなくて
独立してというか 一人で生活したくて
そのアンバラッティカという建物に
そのところにずっと住んでいましたと
で たくさん人々と仲良くして
大勢の人々と付き合って生活することは
普通の世間の常識的な素晴らしい生き方ですけど
仏教の場合はやっぱりあまり認めていない
と言ったっても皆様に認めていないわけではなくて
出家する人々に 皆様には何の関係もないんですけど
出家する人々にはやっぱりグループ生活というか
みんなとワイワイワイワイとね
一緒にグループ組んでグループ組んで
一緒に寝たり食べたり歩いたり座ったり喋ったりするところは
すごいだらしない生き方として禁止というかね
ものすごく良くないとは言ってますね
戒律として禁止ということではないんですが
どうせも戒律なんか形式的に守っていたっても
いつでも仲間と一緒に生活する人々っていうのはやっぱりだらしないと
修行は進まないと 悟りは開けないとは言っているんです
ですから出家したい人々は一応一人で独立して生活した方がいいと
この独立ってどういうことかというと
やっぱりこれは精神的に煩悩がありすぎる場合は
煩悩があればあるほど心っていうのはものすごい弱いものなんですね
ちょっとしたことに感動したり
悲しがったり 驚いたり
落ち込んだりするんですね
心は弱いっていうところで
心はなぜ弱くなるかというと
あらゆる煩悩が心のある時はすごく弱いんですね
強くなるわけじゃないので
例えば欲があるといろんなものについて
その分自分の足が引っ張られているんですね
自由に行動はできません
例えば守らなくちゃいけない大事な財産とかね
仕事とか立場とか何かあると思ったら
それは欲というんですね
私には大事な財産があるんだぞ
大事な親戚がいるんだぞとか
私に大事な立場があるんだぞとか思っちゃうと
そういうものを守らなくちゃいけないんですね
そうするとかなり自由というものはなくなるんですね
例えば国の総理大臣にしてしまえば
その人がすごい権力と財産と持っている
大変なものを持っている人なんですね
ですから 普通の一般の人々のように自由に行動したりすることはできませんし
どこへ行っても厳しい警備の中で
物々しい警備の中で歩いたりする
まあ行ったり来たりするし
それから自分のスケジュールというのは 1 分ごとに単位で
どこに何時何分どこにいるかということまでも全て管理されているんですね
その管理を破っちゃうと
その人の権力までも失ってしまっちゃうし
ですから何かあるという
何か大事にするという
例えばずっと総理大臣で権力者でいたいと思ったならば
かなり自分の足を引っ張られてしまうんですね
で 好き勝手な行動をしたら
それっきりで全部終わってしまっちゃいますね
で 財産持っている人の場合でも
やっぱり財産を守ろうと思っちゃうと
そう自由自在に生活はできなくなるんですね
ですから 欲というものは煩悩でありますし
それがある場合はある場合はその分心は弱くなるんですね
いろんな条件飲まなくちゃいけないし
いろんな条件の中で生活しなくちゃいけない
同じことで怒りがある場合でも
やっぱりまあすごい気をつけて生活しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
怒りがある人にとっては
嫌なものはいらないものだ
気に入らないものっていうのとたくさんなりますから
敵がたくさんいますから
どうやってその敵を潰そうかとかなんとか考えちゃうと
敵を潰すためにいろんなからくり計画立てたりしちゃうと
それはバレないようにとか
あらゆる工夫しなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 例えば好き勝手に
あの人は悪い人だから
気に入らんだから殺しましょうと思っても
思うのは簡単ですけど
それから殺し計画立てたり
殺すを実行したりして
それからそれバレないようにするということも大変なことなんですね
ですから それでどうなるかというと
自由に堂々できることはできなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことで この煩悩があること自体が
すごい心が弱くするということは
お釈迦様の考え方で それは必ずしも俗世間の考え方とは一致はしないのは当たり前当然なことで
俗世間の考え方っていうのは
やっぱり欲がなければ頑張れないんではないか
欲がなければ努力できないんではないか
欲がなければ もうどうやってもチャレンジして人間が進歩するんでしょうかということなんです
ですから 社会的な成功
社会的な地位を獲得するためには
人間にはすごい激しく
欲と怒りとかね そういうわがまま高慢というものがなければできませんというのは俗世間の思考で
だからどちらが正しいかということを第三者が決める
であって まあ私は仏教徒だからね
私に私には気になることはできません
まあ一応出家の生き方としては
お釈迦様はですから この煩悩のない生き方があの大変強い生き方だというふうに言ってますね
それで人間っていうのはすごく怯えて弱いんだから
なぜ怯えているかというと
貪瞋痴っていう煩悩があるんだから
怯えて弱くて まあすごくこの何て言いますか
生きてるという感じがしないぐらい
もうあっちこっちにペコペコと頭下げながらもう生活しなくちゃいけないんですね
で まあすごく腰が低くて
みんなに頭を下げてるんだからと言って謙虚というわけじゃないんです
で まるっきり違う高慢なんですね
欲はありすぎなんですね
だからもう頭下げなければ
腰の低い生活しなかったら自分の財産がなくなるんだということで
すごい惨めな生き方をしてるんですよ
まあ会社とかね 商売やってるところとか見てみると
みんな随分品格がよく
行儀よく 大変な素晴らしい生活で性格ではないかと見えるように
演技は演技はしてますけど
なんでそこまでやってるかというと
そうでなきゃ商売繁盛しないっていうことはもうはっきりしてるんですね
ですから あれは高慢からね
欲から怒りから出てくる行儀というものなんですね
それは世間では行儀として認めますが
仏教ではそんなのは偽善だというふうに言っているんです
その点に至っても 仏教と社会の思考というのはまだ正反対の立場をとっているんです
で それでなんで我々は家族がなければ寂しいやとか
友達がなければ寂しいやと思うのは心が弱いんですからなんですね
ですから 自分の心の弱みをたくさん人々が周りにいることで補っちゃうんですね
それは仏教の考え方 でも世俗的な考え方は
その人はたくさん友達がいて
大変素晴らしいやと 例えば現代日本の社会を見ても
あのもう 24時間みんな携帯をいじってるんですね
ということは まあまあ10分に電話 1本かけるといえばね
もう 1時間  2時間なんて
これ何人かに電話かけてるでしょうかね
そうすると 一人の人はおそらく2
3000人ぐらいの人々と
もしかすると仲良く友達しているでしょうね
そんなに友達いるんでしょうかとも
私には想像できませんですけど
まあ大きな国だから もしかすると一人に1000人
2000人ぐらいね 友達いるかもしれません
自分の国がすごい小さいんだからね
そういうたくさんはいません
そこでこの階段 駅からね
階段上がって外は雨降ってるのに
それ傘差す間でも携帯でまた連絡するというね
まあでことで 我々は階段でじっと待っていなくちゃいけないんです
その人々はその用事終わって外へ出るまでは
まあまあ それぐらいものすごいたくさん人々とコミュニケーション
コンタクトをして 大変幸福で生活していますが
それは世俗的な思考で
仏教から見ればもうそういうのはやってはいけないと
あまりにも心が弱いと
もう誰かと喋らなきゃ寂しくて死にそうになるとかね
友達がいなかったら寂しくて死にそうになるということは
結局は心が弱いということであるし
だから独立する 自立する
自由になるということを目的にしている特定の仏教教えの場合は
そういうこのグループグループを喜んでサンガニカーラーマという言葉を使ってますけど
まあいつでもある もう英語ではグループではなくて click という言葉あります
私の発音はおかしいんですから
わからないかも でも何ですかね
シーライキビューイという言葉なんですけど
click という言葉使いますけどね
でまあ団体とかな グループですけどね
まあ日本だったら例えば暴力団という言葉使ってますね
その場合は団体という褒め言葉ではなくて
ちょっと批判的な言葉になりますね
click って場合もそういうちょっと批判的な意味なんですね
グループといえばいろいろ意味がありますけどね
まあそんなふうな感じで
そういうたくさん click を作って生活すると
やっぱりその分は弱いということで
だから人間っていうのは力をある
頑張れる もうすごいと強いと示すために使う手段っていうのは
何人かと一緒に行動することなんですね
だからそういう生活と悟りの生活っていうのは
残念ながら正反対の生活でですから
この特定の仏教 ブッダの世界では
出家した人々にとっては
あんた方は悟りを開いたければ
解脱を得たければ 全く一人で
誰にも頼らないでしっかりと生活することを習いなさいということで
それでこのラーフラという沙弥でしたけど
沙弥 今この経典の場合は沙弥かどうか分かりませんだけど
これはおそらくお釈迦様の再起の時はいた息子様だと思いますし
だから大体7歳あたりで出家したしね
だからすごい小さな子供なんですね
まあまあ それでもしっかりしていて
子供だからいつでも誰かのそばに寝て寝たいとかね
そういうとこは何もなかったし
きちんと出家だから独立して一人で生活するんだよということ
で グループたくさんお坊さんたちやらいるところから離れて
こういう一人でいることはすごく好きでしたと
子供頃からの ですから
例えとしては 棘はもう植物の中に現れる時からも
もう鋭いと危ないと もう触ったら怪我するんだよという感じで
この棘は誰の棘かというと
お釈迦様の息子ですから
まあお釈迦様と同じく
子供ももうなかなかしっかりしているんだよというふうに
注釈書の褒めの解釈なんですね
次の行
アタコ・バガヴァー・サーヤンナ・サマヤン・パティサッラーナ・ウッティト・ヤーナ・アンバラッティカ・ヤーナ・アヤスマ・ラーフロ・テーヌ・パサンカメ
アタコ・バガヴァー それから釈尊がサーヤンナ
午後ですね サーヤンナ・サマヤン
午後 パティサッラーナ・ウッティト
午後になるまでずっと一人でいるんですね
で その一人でいて そこからまた出かけて
アンバラッティカヤン
アンバラッティカというところにヤーナ・アヤスマ・ラーフロ
ラーフロ尊者がいるところにウパサンカメ
出て行ったと で 一応お釈迦様が食事後
一人で瞑想場に入って
誰とも喋らないで一人でいる時間使ってるんですね
で それ終わったらそのままさっさと自分の息子というかね
今の息子なんですけど
いるところにさっさといらっしゃるんですね
アッ
ダ・サア・コオ・アヤスマ・ラーフロ・バガヴァンタン・ドゥーラトー・アーガッチャンタン・ヴィスワヌ・アーサナン・パンニャー・ペーシ・ウダカンチャ・パーダーナン
アッダ・サア・ミマスタ・コオ・アヤスマ・ラーフロ
ラーフロ尊者がバガヴァンタン
お釈迦様をドゥーラトー・アーガッチャン
遠くからいらっしゃるのを見ましたと
だからお釈迦様が遠くからいらっしゃるのをラーフロ尊者が見ましたっていう風に
この逆で訳しなくちゃいけないんですね
日本語になってくると
で ニシーディ・バガヴァー・パンニャー・テー・アーサネー・ニサッジャ
ヴィスワヌ 見てから お釈迦様にアーサナン・パンニャー・ペーシ
座るところをちゃんと用意して
それだけじゃなくてウダカンチャ・パーダーナン
あの まあ水と はっきりしないんですけど
この まあ一応この足を洗う水と
そちらに座る腰掛けるものとか
いろいろもうさささっと用意しておくんですね
パーダーナンというのは足のということですけど
そこでニシーディ・バガヴァー・パンニャー・テー・アーサネー・ニサッジャ・パーデー・パッカーレーシ
それで用意した椅子に座ってニシーディ
座りました バパンニャー・テー・アーサネー
ニサッジャ 座ってからパーデー
足をパッカーレーシ 洗いましたと
アーヤスミ・アーヤスマーピ・コー・ラーフロ・バガヴァンタン・アビワーデッ・トワー・エーカ・マンタン・ニシーディ
で ラーフロ尊者も ラーアスマイラーフロー
バガヴァンタンアビワデットアオサカサマーニロヨーシテエーカマンタンニシーディカタワラニスワリマスタト
アタコーバガワーパリッタムウダカーワセーサンウダカーダーネータペッ twa アヤスマンタンラーフランアーマンテーシー
その時お釈迦様がパリッタムウダカーワセーサン
パリッタムほんの少々ということで
ウダカアワセーサン まあウダカ水のことうでアワセーサンというのは残したっていう
まああの水入れで少々の水を残して
ウダカーダーネータペッ twa
で まあそれは何か置くものもあったでしょうね
こちら水差しと訳す 注釈の訳を書いてますね
で とにかくこの水容器にお釈迦様がこのまあウダカーダーネーっていうのは水差し水容器みたいですね
で それに少々水を残して
まあわざと残すんですね
残してラーフルソンジャーを呼びます
呼びかけます まあ相手がまあまあいくらでも子供でしょうし
そこでまあ仏教ではやっぱり自分が足を洗うために水を汲んだならば
その汲んだ水で足を洗って
残りは全部捨てる 捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
半分残しておいてはすごく行儀が悪いと
で 水は別な大きな入れ物にあるかもしれませんだけど
そこから自分が足を洗うために水を汲んだのは
その自分で個人的に使おうと思ったものは全部使って
水差しを綺麗にしておかなくちゃいけない
手洗いのトイレの場合も同じことで
みんなに使うためにはたくさん水をどこかに置いてはあるんだけど
個人個人で水入れで持ったものは全部使い切って
まあ繰り返して置かなくちゃいけないんですね
また 口を前に開いたままでも置いてはいけないんですね
だから 水を汲むものは
もう何て言いますか え？ 入れ物を空にして
干しておかなくてはいけないんですね
そういうのは一応仏教の中の決まりで
そこでお釈迦様は逆なことをわざとやるんですね
だからそこはもうちゃんと書いてあるんですね
足を洗っても残しておいて
置いておいて ラーフルソンジャーに話しかけるんですね
パッサシノートアンラーフライマンパリッタムウダカーワセーサンウダカーダーネータピタンティエワンバンテー
でパッサシキミミマスカラーフラ
イマンパリッタムウダカーワセーサン
この少々の水がウダカーダーネータピタン
水容器にあるのはあなた見えますか？と
エワンバンテー その通りに見えます
見えますと エワンパリッタムコーラーフラテーサンサーマンニャンエーサンナッティサンパジャナムサーワーデーラッジャ
エワンパリッタムコーラーフラ
そのようにほんの少々だよと
ラーフラ 何が テーサンサーマンニャン
サーマンニャンっていうのは
サーマンニャンは何でしょうかね
シャモンショーって書いてあります
サーマヌダンマ で サーマンニャンというのは沙門ショーですね
そういうことでまあ 一応注釈ではなくて
我々の訳は沙門証といってもね
あまりわからないということもありますけど
で それに逆らっているわけではないんですが
一応出家した人としての性格
道徳 特色 沙門であることですから
何か徳というかね 何か生き方
性格なければ沙門と言えませんだから
だからどんな人にも人間といえば人間らしいもの
何かなければいけませんし
その場合は出家らしいものなんですね
男といえば男らしい何かないと
もうただ言葉だけで男ということには言えませんし
ですから このそういう道徳
特色 何々らしいものということなんですね
沙門証っていうのは ですから
沙門というのは出家ということで
出家であるならば 出家らしい特色と出家らしい徳
道徳などっていうのはね
そういうものをまとめてこの沙門証と言うんですね
沙門であることを沙門らしいもの
パリッタン とても少ないんだと
もし彼がサンパジャナ・ムサワーで好意に嘘を言うならば
わざとわざと嘘をついているならば
もう沙門であることはもういわゆる沙門らしいものっていうのはほんのわずかだよと
アタコ・バガワタン・パリッタン・ウダカーワセ・サンチャッデットワー・アヤスマンタン・ラーフラン・アマン・テーシー
それからお釈迦様その水を捨てて
チャッデットワーっていうのは捨てて
ウダカーワセサンっていうのは残り水ですね
残り水を捨てて ラーフラ尊者にまた喋るんですね
パッサシ・ノートアン・ラーフラ・タン・パリッタン・ウダカーワセサン・チャッディタン
あなた見たんでしょうかねという
少々水をもう今捨てちゃったんだと
見たでしょうと エワン・バンテー
はい 見ましたと エワン・チャッディタン・コー・ラーフラ・テーサン・サーマンニャン・イェーサン・ナッティ・サンパジャナ・ムサワー・デー・ラッジャー
そのように好意に嘘をつく比丘の場合は
この比丘らしいもの 沙門らしいものっていうのは
このようにチャッディタン
捨てたことになるんだと
だから なんでしょうかね
自分が徳を積もうと思って出家したんだけど
その徳そのものを自分で捨てているんだと
水を捨てたような感じで
戻れないんですね 捨てたものは
ですから 自分で育てるべき道徳というものは
もう初めからもう捨てちゃったと
捨てたっていうことは
好意に嘘をつくことなんですね
アタコ・バガワタン・ウダカーダーナン・ニックッジットワー・アヤスマンタン・ラーフラン・アマン・テーシー
それからお釈迦様ウダカーダーナン
水容器をニックッジットワー
あのー 逆さまにしてね
あの口の方は下に向いておいて
向いておくんで いわゆるあのもう仏教で決まってる通りのお釈迦様するんで
結局は水をまず残して
ラーフル尊者と話しながら
それから水を普通にお坊さん誰でもやってるように
その残り水を捨てて あの水容器をあの口を下に向けて
まあ逆さまにして置いておくんです
置いておきながら話してるんです
ラーフル尊者と そこであなたに
まあこれはこの えっと
こちら倒されているこの水容器を見えますかと
ニクジャンというのは倒されるという意味じゃないんですけど
もしかすると まあ下にこの口を下にしてという訳もありますが
それが正しいと思いますけどね
まあ口を下にして置いておくと
それ私がそう思うんですけど
この学者の方はやっぱり倒したという意味で使ってますけど
ニクジュテっていうのは倒すっていう意味ではないんですけど
もしかすると字証で倒すっていう意味でしょうね
だから ニクジュテはこちらはやっぱり倒れるという訳だからね
うん まあニクジュ 転倒という意味ですから
転倒と言えば逆さまにするっていう意味なんですね
ですから 元のパーリ語の意味はどうであるかはもうしょうがないんです
日本訳は倒れるっていうことになってますからね
で それを使って誤解するしか方法ないんですが
あの ずっとそれで言って私を逆らって
もういろいろ攻撃されてきたんだからね
まあしょうがないんです
まあ一応もともとはニクジャっていうのは逆さまにすることなんです
倒すことじゃないんです
で 転倒の一つだけ漢字取っちゃえば
まあ訓読みと言うんでしょうか
そうすると倒れるという意味なんですけどね
でも倒れると読んだって意味が変わっちゃいますよ
漢字が同じですけどね
だからその日本のその微妙さっていうのは
まあ日本語のプロだから気にしないというね
我々は気にする 転倒の意味と倒れるっていう意味は違うと
外人だからもう一応翻訳で理解しますからね
日本語の場合 倒すっていうと横に倒れることを解釈して
転倒するっていうのはやっぱりひっくり返るっていう意味だから
逆さまという意味も取れるんです
転倒 転倒というのは逆さまなんです
それはわかってます  だけど倒れるって言ったら大体横に倒れるって受け取れます
普通はそういう意味なんですね
今先生が仰ったのは 口の方を上になってるのを逆さまに
ですから転倒っていうことなんです
転倒は正しいんです 転倒っていうのは仏教の用語でも使ってて
概念にも使ってますからね
転倒 仏教では転倒と読むみたいですけどね
そこで一つの漢字だけ取って
訓読みで倒れると読んじゃうと
またまるっきり意味が違う
漢字が同じだからといって意味が同じわけじゃないんですね
まあ大したところではないんですけど
まあこちら一応水入れを逆さまにしておいて
ラーフル尊者に話すんですね
そのようにこの逆さまにしたことになるんだと
いわゆるもう 倒れたことでもよろしいし
まあ逆さまになっているんだと
この道徳の方が まあこの比丘のもし好意に嘘をつく比丘であるならば
もう彼が比丘らしいもの
出家らしいもの 沙門らしいものっていうのは
もう全てもう捨てただけではなくて
もう逆に逆さまにもしているんだと
それからアタコウバガワタンウダカーダナンウックッジットワーヤスマンタンラーフランアーマンテーシー
それからその水容器をウックッジットワー
また元に戻して また元に戻して
いわゆる口が前に上にあるように
また元に戻して で まだラーフル尊者に今見えますかと
マンウダカーダナン この水容器見えますかと
リッタントゥッチャン
リッタン 何もない トゥッチャン
空っぽ で トゥッチャンという場合は
この大体性格的に使う
もうもう性格的にもうもう空っぽやと
何一つも得というものはないということで
まあまあ物理的にはただ空
何もないっていうぐらいのことで
性格に当てはまるとトゥッチャンということはすごいきついんです
で このこの箱は空っぽだよとパーリ語で言うんだったらリッタントゥッチャンと言うんですね
2つ言葉使って リッタンというのは空っぽを
トゥッチャンというのは空っぽ
でもリッタンというのは物理的にエンプティという意味で
トゥッチャンというのはすごいこの
すごく何て言いますか
否定的で もうただのエンプティじゃないんですね
すごくもう否定的なエンプティなんですね
もう空っぽというね 日本語でも同じと思いますが
で この箱は空っぽやと言ったとしてもどうったことはないんですね
でもあなたの頭は全く空っぽですねと言ったら
これはもう批判しているんですね
あなたの頭はピーマンやってよ
笑い  その場合はピーマンが入ってますけど
種が入ってますよね  私に言われたらピーマンぐらいでもありますけどと言いますけど
空っぽといえばやっぱりすごく否定的なこと
でもこの場合はこの両方お釈迦様はうまく使っているんですね
ある物理的な品物にも使って
同じことを性格に合わせてみるという
ものすごくもう上手にその単語の使い方なんですね
物理的なことを説明するために使う同じ単語を性格にも使う場合
そのケースそのものを取ってちゃんと教えているところなんですね
ですから ラーフルソンジャに今この水容器を空っぽであることを見えますかと
はい 見えます 空っぽですよと
エワンリッタントッチャン
それで性格に合わせるんです
そのように何もない空っぽやと
誰かシャマンがもう故意に嘘をつくんだったら
彼の道徳というものはもう何もない
空っぽだ だから故意に嘘をつくことにことが恥じないならば空っぽであるという
そこで一つの この経典のアイデアが順番で進んでいきますので
その辺で一つのアイデアのセットなんですね
で 一つのこの定義するんですね
サンパジャナムサワで故意に嘘をつくこと
それについてはラッジャー恥じなくちゃいけないんだと
で だからやっぱり計画立てて
わざとわざとこうやって騙そうではないかということで計画立てて嘘をつくことなんですね
そういうことはものすごいみっともないと恥じなくてはいけないという
一つ道徳的な仏教の考え方があるんですね
で まあそのポイントをお釈迦様はこの説明してあげるんですね
だから相手は 7歳か もう一歳かもしれませんですけど
相手は子供であって その上自分の息子でもあるんですね
だからこのその子供に対して
この偉そうな このもう難しい
もうもう理屈言ったっても意味がないんですよ
でもすっごい難しい理屈でも
まあ大人に分からなくても
子供にはきちんと わかるんですね
で ただその時はどのような単語を使うかっていうぐらいのことで
内容じゃないんです だから子供に喋る場合は
この単語さえ選べば どんな難しいこともよくわかるんですよ
だからこの大人の場合は
このわかりやすい単語を使うとバカにするんですね
相手を そうするとすごい難しい単語やら表現やら
もういろんな人々の隠喩やらね
言わなくちゃいけない
そうすると この人をよく知ってるんだぞということで
結局アイディアがごちゃごちゃになるんですね
例えばブッダの話を説明するために
ソクラテスがこう言ったと言ったって
まるっきり違うことでしょうに
そういう連中何言ったっても関係ないし
だから 俗世間のゴミ箱の話やらカラスの話やら
もう野良犬の話やら言うと
すごくなんかもうね すごいもうニコッと笑ってバカにして聞くんですね
だからまあ大人にはそういうわけで
この性格的にはすごい難しい
仏教っていうのはもう納得いかなくてもいいんですが
物事納得いかなくても理解ぐらいできますけど
理解も難しくなるんですね
納得いるところまでは行ってないんですね
子供の場合はもう難しいことはわからないんだから
もうわからないこと言ったらすぐあっち向くんだから
子供っていうのは 全然聞く気持ちにならないんだから
だからもうすごい単純なというか
子供にわかる単語を選ぶと
その単語を選んで どんな難しいことを言っても
すぐ「ああ はい わかりました」っていうことになるんです
時々私も本当にわかったのかと心配するときも
全然向こうは何のこともないんで 「
わかりましたから」と言ってまたもう態度取っちゃうんですね
まあおそらくわかるでしょうね
で 反応を見たら やっぱりまあわかってるんだっていうこともなんとなくわかるし
で まあそういうことで
それなりに子供の言葉使って
こちらは子供の言葉がないんですけどね
これはもう大人の経典だからね
で こちらは子供の言葉ないんだけど
お釈迦様はそれなりに
まあラーフラソンじゃと
まあもう子供でしょうし
それなりにもう「見てよ
もうミスがちょっとしかないでしょうね」とかね 「
そうですね」とかね 「
それはですね こういうことや」と
人間の場合が 出家している人はね
もう故意に嘘つくんだったらね
嘘をつくとは「まあ嫌だ」とかね 「
恥ずかしいや」とかね 「
嘘なんかつくもんかと
そう思わなきゃ まあ性格っていうのはこんなもんだよ」と 「
小さい 少ないんだろう」と
捨てて 「そういう人っていうのは
自分の立派な人間であることはもうとっくに捨ててるんだよ」と
それからさらにそれを逆さまにして 「
そういう人々の人格っていうのは
もう もう何もない もう逆さまや」と
それでまた元に戻して 「
元は空っぽでしょうし
そういう人々こそ この故意に嘘をつくことを恥じらない人々こそ
全くの空っぽな人間だよ」と
言うとその子供の心に
たとえとこの道徳っていうのにピシッと入っちゃうんですよ
何も反論はなし 何も抵抗がなく
あのたとえから心に真理が染み込むんですね
そういうことで すごいわかりやすく
お釈迦様がラーフルソンジャにわかりやすく
大人にはわかりにくいかもしれませんだけど
説明したんですね そこで
それから一応心が落ち着いてきましたので
次のセットにお釈迦様は説明を持っていくんです
［外国語］すごい長いな
［外国語］文章長いんですが
この意味はそれほど難しくはないと思います
そこからこの象の例えにいくんですね
ラーフラようかな まあ例えば
例えば長柄のような牙を備え
巨大強種にして歴戦の王像
王様の像ですね がいるとします
彼が戦いに出かけ 前足によって行動し
後ろ足によっても行動し
全身によっても行動し
後身後ろの体ですね によっても行動し
頭によっても行動し 耳によっても行動し
牙によっても行動し 尾によっても行動しながら鼻だけは守っているとするならば
それについて上象兵士はこのように思います
この王像は王様の像は長柄のような牙を備え
巨大な容姿にして歴戦のものである
彼は戦いに出かけ 前足によっても行動し
後足によっても行動し
全身によっても行動し
後身によっても行動し
頭によっても行動し 耳によっても行動し
牙によっても行動し 尾によっても行動しながら鼻だけは守っている
王様には命が捨てられていないとというところです
王像が  日本語の訳の仕方として
巨大ってものすごい大きな容姿って言ったら血統の良い
で 歴戦の王道っていうのは
歴戦 戦いをいっぱいした歴史のある像がいるとしますっていう意味だと思う
日本語の方はね  そこら辺は問題ないんですけど
どこかでちょっとごまかしがあるんです
この命を与えさせて捨ててないというところは
ちょっとわかりづらい
命が捨てられていないとっていうことですね
うんうん で こちらでそんなにも例え話だからね
そんな難しいことじゃない
まあインドでは昔は王の軍隊の一部は象隊ですね
で だからかなり象が象隊がよくできてるんだったら
国はかなり安定しているんですね
で そうとはそう簡単には戦えませんだから
だから調教するんですね
あの戦争戦闘に出て戦うために
で まあこちらでわざとすごい出来のいい
もうかなり巨大な象のことを例え話に持ってくるんですね
体が小さくて そういう
たちではなくて もうかなり大像ですね
象の中でもかなりもう牙もすごいできてあって
もう体格もある もう巨大な像がいて
その像は訓練 調教を受けて
歴然的なそうでも怖いものはないと
言ったらもう何でも壊してしまうと
で この像が戦いに行ったところで
もうもうだいたいもうもう壊したものは倒したものは頭でぶつけたらもうすぐ倒せる
体でこうやってぶつければ倒れる
大体そうっていうのは体全体で戦うんですよ
それはゾウの性格でその通りなの
それはさらに訓練するとうまくもっとできるんです
ゾウはこの体が大きい割にはどんな部分でもものすごい上手に使う
そこでこの胴体でぶつけて壊す時もある
時々いたずらも好きだからね
よくやるんですね ゾウっていうのは
いたずらでも 例えばこのゾウ使いのこと
ちょっと気に入らないとか
時々機嫌が悪くなってお互いに喧嘩したりする時もあります
でも ゾウ使いと気に入らなくても
喧嘩して殴ったり蹴ったりすることもできないし
人間だからね そこら辺気をつけて怒らせてやるぞと思って
すごく落ち着いて丁寧にいるんですよ
あの鼻もあまり振り 振りすくともしないで
それで それでこうやってゆっくりゆっくりで
何かにこうやって体寄せるんですね
そこら辺にある何かに
それでその建物やら店でやるか
それって倒れちゃう で
私は知らんという感じで
だからそういうこともわざとやるってことはすぐバレちゃいますけど
また何のことなくいるんです
で その時はやっぱりゾウ使いはすごく怒られますけど
怒ったってすごい損失なんだから
その人 それから移動に会いますからね
だからゾウの勝ちなんですけど
もう だからこのおとなしくいるんだから
もうゾウ使いもまあいいんじゃないかっていうことで
その瞬間見て ちょっと体ちょっと横に
そうやっても倒れちゃう
で 鼻が上げたりすると分かります
明確に分かりますから
すぐ落ち着きなさいと言っちゃうし
足上げちゃうと分かりますから
それはやらせません それは分かるんだから
もう体でやっちゃうとかね
かなりもう頭使うゾウゾウっていうのはね
で ですから この後ろ足でもね
前足でも適当に使う この木材とかね
運んだりする場合は もう運べるように整える場合は
それは自分で考えて整えちゃうんですね
その時前足使うか後ろ足使うか
これはもうその時その時考えて使いますね
そこをね わざともうこちらではゾウが前足やら後ろ足やら体やら頭やらもう全部使ってるんだと
その上もう耳も使って耳で何使うかわかりませんだけど
耳ではもう何も まあおそらく日を消すぐらいかもしれませんですけど
尾っぽも尾も使っているんだと
まあ尾はまあもう人を一応殴るぐらいはできるかもしれませんですけどね
まあとにかくそこまで使っても
いわゆる体全て使っているんだと
牙も使っているんだと
徹底的に戦ってる もう文句はない
ゾウの場合は この大ゾウは文句なく全身で戦っている
しかし 鼻は使わないと
鼻はまあその場合は決まって口の中に入れておくんですね
頭で何かやる場合は決まって鼻は口の中に入れておくんですね
鼻を守りたいんですよ
これ倒すためには やっぱり鼻使ったらあかんぞとわかったら
もうすぐ口の中に入れて頭で攻撃するんですね
ゾウは攻撃ということないんだから
別に誰しも攻撃しないで
何か倒したければそうやってやりますし
で 木とかね 倒したいんだけど
時々鼻でこうやってちょっと曲がって捕まって
それから頭で倒す場合もあります
その時は自分でも一応気を捕まっておいた方がいいなと自分で判断してね
その場合だと おそらく小さな細い木の場合で
あれ綺麗好きだからね
あんまり泥やら色々もうすくうのは葉っぱなんかにそれも好きじゃないし
ですからもう倒して鼻でまだ取って
それから丁寧に置いて葉っぱ食べたりもしますね
まあそういうこと とにかく全て使って戦ってるんですけど
鼻だけ守っているんだと
鼻が守っているということはどういう意味でしょうかと
このゾウの上に乗っている兵士が考えるんですね
このゾウはもう文句なし
戦ってはいますが 自分の命は捨てられてない
死にたくはない 言うんだったらやってやるぞとね
私のことを放っておけという感じなんですね
そんな戦争で戦っても死にたくないんだぞという
あんまりこのもう全身で心も込めてやってるわけじゃないということなんですね
だから自分の命を守りながら
守りながら戦っているという意味になるんだと
そこで何がわかるかというと
気をつけて よく緊張じゃない
慎重に戦っているということなんですね
慎重に戦う場合は 何でしょうかね
危ないと思ったらどうしますかね
逃げちゃうんですよ 慎重に戦う場合はとにかく戦うんじゃないんですよ
あ これはちょっと危ない
もう隠れましょうと 自分の命にはちょっと危険だなとわかったら
そこですぐもう引いて
もう戦わない あ 大丈夫とわかったらそこで戦うという
いつでも命を優先に守るんですね
ですから 何でもやってくれるってわけじゃないんですね
この慎重に戦う場合は
そこで次の文章はまた省略でもよろしいし
次に象が鼻も使う 体も足も尻尾も何だかんで頭も全部使って
牙も使って もう今度は鼻も使うと
ソンダーヤピカンマンカロティ
まあこの鼻という言葉
あんまりよくないんですけどね
まあ象にとっては鼻じゃないんですから
あれは英語でもノーズとは言わないんです
パーリ語でも鼻はナーサなんですね
象の場合はナーサという言葉を使わないんです
ソンダ 英語でもトランクと言うんですね
ノーズと言わないんです
日本語では鼻だけですかね
まあ日本では象が昔はいたんですけどね
何でしたっけ 昔の象は
マムシとかね もう食べちゃったでしょ
全部 クジラも食べてるんだから
まあとにかく日本中国文化ではね
そんなに象っていうのはね
生活に近い動物ではないんですから
言葉ないと思いますけどね
一応あの鼻はちょっと良くないなと思いますけどね
あれの場合はね あれすごい大胆な道具だからね
象の場合はそれは手でしょうしね
手よりもすごい まあほんの小さなものでも分別できるし
あのあの分厚いあの鼻の先にあるあの三角形の部品で
そこで手に何か食べられるものと食べないものを入れて
はい どうぞって言ったら
手に人間の手に入れるものだから小さいものでしょうね
ちゃんと食べられるものだけ取って食べちゃうんですね
でも機嫌が悪いんです
それもうからかってるとわかっちゃうと
だから相当遊ぶ時は気をつけた方が
相手のことを大事に尊敬しないとあまり良くないんですけど
で そう出しちゃうと あの例えば豆とかね
そこら辺食べられない何かもあっちゃうと
それは別にして あれだけ取ってちゃんと取るんですよ
それぐらい小さなこともできるし
それから力あることをものすごい大胆なことしようと思ったら
もう鼻でまたできるし
すごい力なんですね それから水を飲むわ
シャワーをするわ で 何でもするんですから
すごい道具なんですね
それで食べる葉っぱやら何でもいくらか綺麗にして食べれますから
で ちゃんとこうやって振って振って食べるでしょうし
それから葉っぱにこの食べられない
この何て言いますか 芯のようなものありますね
あのヤシの葉っぱだったらね
芯があって それは食べられません
我々も一応包丁でこの葉っぱだけ欲しい場合は
あるいは芯だけ この箒なんか使う場合はヤシの葉っぱの芯だけ使うんですね
なんかすごいすごく立派ですよ
あれは このあの 日本の箒の場合
別なもの使いますけど
それより硬くて長持ちもする
だからそういう芯取りをこっち私たちだと何か刃物使って取るんですけど
要は何もなく綺麗に芯を抜けて葉っぱだけ取って
こうやって綺麗に折って葉っぱだけずっと引っ張るんですね
それで鼻で葉っぱは途中で折れないように綺麗に押さえて
あれがもう本当に技ですよ
我々がもうこれほど慣れている指やらあるんですけど
もうできない 力もないことも確かなので
1本の葉っぱだったらなんとかできますけど
3本やるともう指がもうもうかなり痛くてやられちゃうんですね
すごく すごい上手 とにかくゾウの鼻っていうのは
まあかなりの立派な道具なんですね
だから鼻っていうのはちょっとゾウに怒られるかもしれませんという気持ちもありますけど
子供の面倒を見る時でもかなり上手に鼻使いますよ
まあ自分の子供たちの面倒見たりすると
やはり人間のこと 人間の場合でも
この子供に対してゾウはすごい親切ですからね
で 大人を何かしちゃうと
ゾウの鼻がぶつかっちゃうとね
もうかなりもう衝撃が多い
あまり痛くはないんですけど
衝撃が多いんです 倒れちゃうとね
それまで警戒するかもしれない
子供相手だったらね すごい柔らかく優しく優しく触ったり
捕まったり あげたりもします
で もう痛くも何もない
ゴムバンドで巻いてあげたような感じだからね
すごい丁寧に もう力加減っていうのはすっごく知っている
そういうことだから ゾウにとってはものすごい大事な部品なんですね
この鼻は それでも鼻でももう攻撃することになっちゃうと
ゾンラーイビカンマンカロティ
もうやがて鼻でも戦うことにすると
パリッチャッタンコーランニョーナーガッセジービタン
このコーランニョーナーガッセジービタン
文章はなんかすごい意味が取りづらいというかね
ギワナ ランニョーナーガッタン
まあとにかく鼻も使う場合は
あの兵士があ このゾウはもう命ももう捨てたっちゃと
っていうことになるんですね
鼻も使う もうもう命も捨てたったと
こいつは  鼻はゾウにとって最後の砦ですね
守らなきゃいけないんだから
一番大事  鼻を傷つけられたら命を取られたのと同じことって意味でいいんですか
だから鼻だけは何としてでも守るもの
守らなければならない
それもなくなったら もう死んじゃってもどうったことはない
いわゆるもう死んでも構いませんということになっちゃうと
鼻も使うということなんです
ですから まあこのゾウはもう死んでも構いませんと
もう死んでも戦うぞとも思ったんだと
もう守れません 命は 命守れない気持ちは鼻でわかるんですね
鼻使ってるんだから それで兵士がこう思いますね
ナッティダーニキンチランニョーナーガッサアカロニヤ
これからこの大ゾウにはもうできないことはないんだと
もう遠慮しない どうせもう死んじゃいますから
もうやりたいことを何でもやっちゃうという
とにかくもう死ぬ覚悟ですから
もう何でもやっちゃうと
[音楽
]エヴァメヴァコーラーフラヤッサカッサチサンパージャーナムサーラーデーナッティラッジャーナーハンタンスキンチパパァンアカラニーヤンティヴァダーメこのように
ラーフラあるシャモンが好意に嘘つくことにことを恥じらないならば
彼にできない罪できない悪いことっていうのはないんだと
何でもできる 悪いこと
悪 悪行 で まあすごいわかりやすい例えだと思いますね
そこでこの象の場合は鼻で攻撃しちゃうと
もう何でもやる だって普通命守りたい場合は火があるところにはゾウは行かない
火にはすごく弱い それで
あれ結構痛いんです ゾウの体はね
ほんのちょっと怪我しちゃってもすごく痛がったりもする
でも戦闘に行くゾウはそれは気にしない
訓練させてます あのちょっとだけの火なんかはあんまり気にしない
一応戦闘に持っていく場合は
体は矢に火つけないのにいろいろ舗装してあげますけど
あの それで命まで捨てたら
ここら辺ボーボーと火が燃えてあっても
そこら辺さっと行って先に行って戦うという気にしないんですね
逆にゾウの上に座ってる兵士
対戦相手 危うく状態になる
何するかわからない 上に人が乗ってるんではないかと気をつけなくともない
もう火があろうと 上から何か落ちてこようか
もうそれ気にしないで
とにかく行って戦って戦って
もう死ぬまで何でもやるということ
それで出家したシャモンが好意的に嘘を言うならば
嘘を言うことを恥じらないならば
その人にとってはどんな悪でもどんな罪でも平気でできるんだよと
ということで ですから
そこでお釈迦様が言いたがっているのは
あの最低好意的に嘘を言うことを言わない
言わないというぐらいは守りなさいと
何でも守るきれないかもしれませんだけど
最低好意に嘘をつくと
それぐらいのどこでも守れと
それ守らなきゃもう全部やったことと同じだと
どんな悪いことでもできると
だから道徳の場合は人格構成性
構成の場合はもうこの行為に嘘をつくことはものすごい
この命というか基本の柱
大黒柱というかね もうそれが柱なんですね
それによって他の建物の他の部品ができあがっちゃいますからね
まあ橋に例えたっても
今の現代 ものすごいすごい柱が一つくるでしょうね
その柱の上ですごい幅広い橋が作っちゃうし
ですから この下に入り込んでる柱がすごく大事なものなんですね
そこでこちらで理解してほしいのは
仏教の道徳の世界では
あの柱はこの嘘つくなかれっていうことなんです
好意に嘘つくなかれということ
で それは仏教の独特の
徳の考え方はそうして理解した方がよろしいんですね
世の中で倫理学っていうのはもうかなり進んで広げて
もうかなり複雑で進んでいますから
いろんな話があるかもしれません
ブッダの話はそんなに複雑ではなくて
すごい単純でしょうし
ブッダがお釈迦様がおっしゃっている道徳の道徳はたくさんあるんですけど
一応柱は土台は故意に嘘をつくということにしているんですね
それを仏教の道徳の特色として
すごい悪い罪って何なのかといえば
もうみんなは平気で何とか言うでしょう
仏教から言えば嘘をつくことなんですね
世の中でいろんな悪いことあるでしょうに
子供を殺すことやら女殺すことやら
もうあらゆることがありますね
で その中 だから世間にあるいろんな知識人たちが構成している道徳の世界では
もういろんな話があると思います
私は勉強していないんだから
あまり何も言えませんですけど
あらゆる道徳というか
罪というかね やってはいけないことの中で
もうどちらか一つ大事な
どうしても守らなくちゃいけないことは何なのかといえば
嘘をつくことというふうに仏教はなっているんです
そのポイントにおいて考えたっても
仏教と俗世間は違います
だから 強引にブッダに世間の俗世間の話を教えてやるぞと踏ん張るのではなくて
我々にも俗世間の考え方とにかく押し付けて
この馬鹿どもたちに教えてあげるぞというふうに頑張るんじゃなくて
それぞれ考え方は違いますよと平和的に理解した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
だから 相手の教えを強引に押し付けようとすると
こちらも攻撃するんですね
だから違いでありますと理解しておけば
それで平和的に知識人として理解できると思います
俗世間では嘘を言うことは決して悪いとは思ってないと思います
嘘をつくことは一つの美徳であって
いかに上手に嘘をつくかということをすごい立派なことであって
嘘をつくんだからといって
決して人間はダメだということは
俗世間では全然言わない
嘘をついた方が立派なんですね
でもだからといってお釈迦様も同じことを言いなさいと今更言ったってお釈迦様もいないしね
それから私にそんなことを責めても
嘘っていうのは大事な手段ではなくて
来るためって私は知ったことじゃないんだから
それはね だから私にはどうすることもできない
ブッダの教えを教えるしかね
私の教えではないし 私は日蓮聖人でもないし
そういうふうになったら
自分の教えを これこそ私こそブッダよというふうに言えますけどね
それもできませんしね
ですから 仏教の道徳の場合は
それをこのサンパジャナムサーワダという行為に嘘をつくということは
大変な柱になると だから何百億個ぐらい道徳があっても
すべての道徳の柱と根元になっているのはこれということになっていますね
それから子供にさし躾をするんですね
で タスマティヘテーラーフラ
だからラーフラ君はハッサーピ
冗談ででも笑うためにでも
ナムサーバニッサーミ
嘘だけは言わないんだよと
ちょっと笑っちゃうために
ちょっとからかって笑っちゃうためにでも
子供だからね いっぱい遊んだりする可能性もあるしね
ですから冗談で笑うためにでも嘘をつかないんだぞというふうに
エーワンヒテーシッキタッバン
よく覚えておいてください
自分を戒めてくださいと
だから冗談ででも嘘を言わないんだよと覚えておけば
この仏教で考えているこの行為に嘘をつくという大変別な罪があるんです
嘘にもたくさんランクがありますから
例えばこの漫才とかなんとかの場合はね
もうまんまと嘘言うでしょうね
でもあれは嘘というふうに計算しませんね
なぜならば 聞いている人々は知っているんだからね
堂々と嘘を言っているということは
聞いてる人も知っていて
嘘だからみんな笑っちゃうんですね
ですから その場合は笑ってお金儲かって生活したいでしょうね
笑わせて 笑うためにわざと嘘を言う
だから嘘を言うことは職業になっていて
でもあれは人を騙すために言ってるわけじゃないんです
決して漫才聞いて騙されたということはないんだから
ですから 嘘の罪にはなるわけじゃないんです
でも 言っていることは事実ではないんだから
まあ一応嘘は嘘ですけど
嘘つきだっていうことまでは言えませんし
まあそういうことだから
ラーフルソンジャに もう君は冗談ででも嘘をつかないんだぞと覚えておけば完璧だと
だからお釈迦様が道徳を教える場合は
どれほど真剣に気をつけて言うか
だからラーフルソンジャが自分を守るための時は完璧に守らなくちゃいけないんでしょうね
そこで素晴らしい基準を教えてあげるんですよ
冗談ででも いわゆる人をちょっとからかって笑わせたいと
笑わすためにでも嘘つかないんだよと決めておけば
もう安心でしょ だからずっと自分の子供の面倒は見られませんし
こうやってちょっと時間
暇 暇があったらすぐちょっと行って
もうしゃべって様子を見て帰ってるんですよ
その時は他のお坊さんたちに説法してたり
これから説法しますから
ちょっと昼休みを終わったら
またまた他のお坊さんたちも瞑想中で昼休み中なんですね
その隙間に自分の息子のところに行ってます
すぐ帰ってくるんですよ
ですから その瞬間だけでも
お釈迦様がきちんとラーフルソンジャに立派な坊さんとして出家達者をして成長するために必要なアドバイスをちゃんとしているんですね
で そこまではこの嘘 嘘についてのお話で
それからもうもうちょっと心が落ち着いたでしょう
ラーフルソンジャの場合は
それでもうちょっと幅広く道徳を語っていくんです
では そこら辺で終了いたします
何か質問ありますか  仏教書とか
禅の中でとか 会員する中でというか
そのところであるんですけど
4番目に来るんですけど
今一番の柱っていう話だったんですけど
その 4番目に敢えて置かれてるっていうのは何か意味があるんですか
どうでしょうね 一応道徳リストっていうのは
おそらくインドは一般的にあっちこっちで出来上がったものだと思いますね
別にお釈迦様の発見という
道徳は人間の生き方だから
悪いことってのは人間がやっていることだから
お釈迦様現れる以前 人類が現れた時から悪いことをやっていましたから
だから道徳概念っていうのは人間に一般的にあるものだから
このリストっていうのはそうやって誰のものというよりも
一般的に あの なんていうのは秩序というか
クリスタライズというか
構成になると思いますね
それでお釈迦様の時代では
インドでは動物を平気で殺していたでしょ
神様宗教儀式として インド人はそんなに動物殺す人殺す文化ではでしたとは思いませんだけど
みんな農民の方が多かったし
この狩りとかね そんななかったでしょうし
特に牛っていうのは昔もあの農業やら生活に使うね
家畜動物で食って食べるために育てたわけじゃないんですよ
インド昔でも大事な財産だと
財産食って殺して食べちゃうとね
なくなりますからね なのに宗教の世界で生贄っていうことは平気でしたからね
インドの社会で それで自分では普段日常生活では殺して食べ
にも関わらず じゃあでは宗教儀式やりましょうというところで
何百頭殺すかってことになっちゃうんですね
だからそれは普通食べるために動物を殺すよりも残酷なんですよ
人が食べるものがなくて
もうどうにもない時は何か取って殺して食べたっても
そこまでいちいち文句言えないでしょうに
どう見たっても 飢えている人がね
そこら辺に何かもう石でも持っていって
何か動物を倒して もう寝ている犬でもいいんだけどね
もう頭を潰して それから肉を焼いて食べたと言ったってもね
何も言えないでしょ でも神様のためにこの百頭を差し上げますと言って
みんなもう大げさで殺すと
これすごい残酷で あまりにも酷いんですよ
だからこのインパクトはインドにあったと思いますね
それでジャイナ教もちょっとお釈迦様よりは古いし
はっきりとそれにはもう攻撃するんですね
絶対殺すことは絶対ダメだと
命あるものは取ってはいけませんと
そういうことだから 殺すなかれということは
すごい道徳としてハイライトする必要がものすごくあったんですね
で 損は目に見えるんですね
それで一般的にこの道徳のリストで殺すなかれということは
十悪の場合も同じことで前に来ているんですね
そこで十悪のリストは五戒よりも古いんです
十悪 十善というのはね
で 古いとかどちらでしょうかね
はっきりはしないんですけど
この五戒時とつになる場合もあるし
いろいろもうあれまあ戒律ですからね
数はその時その時適当にもう五にするか六にするか八にするか
適当に使いちゃいますからね
まあそういうことで この
窃盗やらね 盗むことやらね
まあはっきりと あの 何て言いますか
損が見えてるんだからわかりやすいんですよ
嘘ついたらどれくらい損するか
あんまり見えませんね
そういうふうなことで
この普通我々から見れば
この道徳を守る我々から見れば
インパクト強いところから始めたんではないかなとは思いますね
それでも誰でも嘘をつくんだから
いきなり嘘は一番目になっちゃうとみんな逃げる可能性がありますね
誰も守ってくれない可能性もあります
無理やと そこで窃盗するなかれ
それだったらまあできますよということで
頑張れますよということで元気が出てくる
盗むなかれというのは
まあ別に盗まなくても大丈夫やと
私は今まで別に盗んだことでもないし
ですから まあ守れんわけじゃないんだよと
言って すごく何て言いますか
自信がつくでしょ それで欲しない行為するなら
まあいいんじゃないか
まあ頑張ってみますということで
ってなっちゃうでしょうし
そこでみんなやってる嘘について言ったら
やっぱりそういえばね
嘘つくのは良くないと何のことなく受けるんですよ
あの順番でいくと そこでさらに悪いと世の中で思ってない
みんなやってることを先になっちゃうんですね
嘘をつくことをみんなはやってますけど
やっぱりやらん方がいいという気持ちがあるんですね
酒飲むことをみんなやってますけど
それがすごい楽しいとやらん方がいいって気持ちさえもないんですよ
そういうわけで なんかすごい立派に順番になってる
と聞いたら 別に私は今までもそんなに殺したわけでもないし
まあ守れますよと 盗むなかれったら別に盗んで生活してきたわけじゃないんだからね
たとえ盗んで生計を立てた人にしても
盗むなでは今日からなんとか仕事をして生活しますよと言って頑張れるしね
そういうふうな順番じゃないかなと
その順番で考えちゃうと
うまい具合に順番なんですよ
世間は一はすごい悪いという
二は次に悪いと思う 三は三番目に悪いと思っている
四はみんなやってるんですけど
やっぱり悪いと思っている
五はまあ別にということで思っているんですね
だから犯すフリークエンシーで見れば
五はすごく犯していて
四も犯していてね 三も犯してますけど
数は少ない 二はより数が少ない
一はもっと数が少ないんですね
[笑い]だからそこで守る場合は
そういう数少ないところから犯す人の数が少ないんだから
自分がやっぱり犯さないグループにどうせ入ってるんですね
そこから入りやすいんじゃないかなと思いますね
そういうことです それから仏教は悪っていうのは身口意に 3つに分けてますね
で 身口意に分けてる場合も同じ順番
体の行為 言葉の行為 意の意識的な行為と
戒律というものは必ずしも体と言葉だけで意は入りません
意っていうのは考え方
思考だから 別の中 重悪の場合は別に入りますけどね
それでも罪が少ないのは体の行為なんですね
体の罪は重さが少ないんですね
言葉の罪はより重いんです
意の罪はもっと重いんです
で それは仏教の順番で
でも世間はそうは思ってないんですね
逆に思ってるんで 悪いこと考えたってやってないんだからいいんじゃないかと
世間の思考は逆さまですね
仏教の視点は身口意で強烈になるんです
世界は意口身でだよと
意はすごい軽いんだと
言葉で言っただけだからね
大したことはないんだと
体でやることがすごい罪だというふうに思っていて
ジャイナ教もその順番なんですね
仏教とは違う それで仏教とジャイナ教は結構ぶつかったんですね
なんであんたはこの意識的な行為はそんなに悪だと言ってるんですかと
違うんではないかと 体の罪はすごい大きいではないかと
もう戦ったことも結構あるし
仏教は全然逃げません
はっきりと意の行為は罪が重いと思っているんですね
それで律作作る場合は
この身口意という順番で作るんですね
そうすると殺すなかれっていうのは体
盗むなかれは体 欲しがらない行為するなかれも体ですね
嘘をつくなかれっていうことは言葉
酒飲むなっていうことは体でやってますけど
なんで酒飲まないと言っているのはもう頭が悪くなるんだからですよ
別に普通の飲み物やとかね
調味料やとかね 薬やというふうに思っちゃうと
別にどうったことないんです
どうせ薬には酒使うっていうね
場合もあるし インド薬の場合はこのいろんな薬草使いますから
この薬草の薬分を取り出すために自然に発酵させるんですよ
それも一つの薬の方法なんですね
薬草やらいっぱい持ってきて
これ潰して潰して あらゆるものを入れて
もうそれの中にこの 何て言いますか
黒砂糖ですね 黒砂糖か
この黒蜜とかね ありますので
それもたくさん入れて
もう何年  1年  2年とか
そのまま覆っておくんですね
だからこのその場合は自然発酵してアルコール性
水分が出てきて 入れた薬草は全部水分を溶かせてくれるんですね
ですから それは正真正銘の薬で飲んでも酔っ払うわけじゃないし
薬草の成分のあまりの強くて
だからそれで激しく発酵することもできません
ただ発酵すると激しく発酵しますけど
これはいろいろ薬入れてるんだからね
まあそういうこともありますからね
そこら辺まで言ってるわけじゃなくて
これアルコール飲む このいわゆるただアルコール飲むという行為はね
これは禁止しているんですね
麻薬使うという その行為自体が禁止しているんですね
なぜならば もうそれはとにかく頭がおかしくする目的でやってますね
ですから まあ本当は体の行為なんですけど
何か飲む 飲むことだからね
吸うことだから体の行為なんですけど
5番目に入れてるんで
そうするとちゃんと身口意に身口用の順番になってるんですね
ですから 今更アルコールの戒律を 1に持ってくることもできないし
あの仏教の道徳論では嘘はすごい柱だからといって
あの嘘を少なからず 4番目を 1に持ってくることもできない
それなりにかなりみんな考えてみんなではなくてね
昔は全部考えてあるんです
今更変えられることはできません
いわゆる変えられません
どんな知識人が来てどう考えたって
向こうはもう仏教の世界はもう全部もう
完全に考えて終わって
これで終わりと終了結論としていますからね
だからもう 200年  2000年も経ってますけどね
変えられません だからこのいい加減で手当たり次第でできてるわけじゃない
1つも リストの順番どたっても
すごいそれなりにすごい意味があってリストセットしてるんですよ
その意味で理解すると
まあそのまま理解するしかもう道がない
私たちの思考はもうまだまだもうあまりにも未熟で
それには勝てないと思いますよ
お坊さんの知識には そういうわけで
このまあ 一応道徳の場合
10種類のリストしかないんですけどね
十善十悪という その場合もちゃんと身口意の順番にしています
で 八正道は道徳で 八正道の場合もちゃんとこのシーラ
サマーディ パンニャーに分けてあって
まあその時は戒律のところは真ん中に入ってきますけど
それは仏教の特別な道として
仏教独特の道として 智慧で始めて智慧で終わるんだそうと
だから仏教の道徳はやっぱり智慧の勝負だから
体を管理することではないし
心を管理することでも
口を管理することじゃない
心そのものを管理することで心そのものを悟らせることなんですね
ですから 仏道は智慧で始めて智慧で終わるんです
ですから サンマーディって正見で始めて
最後にあのサンマサマーディ
症状で終わっちゃうんですね
ですからそちらはもうだから正語などは真ん中なんですね
それももう厳密にその順番でしか成り立ちません
どう踏ん張っても 何にしたっても
なんとか納得してはじまらないと
だから仏教徒には一応 2種類いますよ
ただやるぞでやってる人々と
何か理解して納得してやる人々と
例えば私みたいにあまりにも強引でもう独裁的で喋ると
もうあまりにも抑えられちゃって
もう嫌なんですけど まあ一応やるっていうね
だからまあそういうことと
やっぱり納得してね やっぱりその中で納得して実践する人々の方がやっぱり格が上なんですよ
だから納得するためには
やっぱり智慧が必要なんですね
納得したらそれから嘘つかないんだと
嘘つかないってことは
体の行為 言葉の行為 納得してると
これから殺生しませんよと始まりますが
やっぱりスタートは意なんですね
納得したんだということで
そういうことだから 仏道の場合は善行為の場合は
まあ身口意順番ではなくて
意から意の行為から始めて
意の行為で終わるんだですよ
中に信と法は入ります
間に それは八正道のリスト
ということです じゃ  すみません
はい  あの 養命酒っていう薬草のお酒があるんですけど
あの 昔は私の世代ですが
あのお酒かなと思って飲むのをやめたんですけれども
そういうのは あの 仏教的にいうとお酒の部類に入るんですか？ それは飲む人の気持ち次第と言えばそれであって
酒類とはもう変わり 我々には飲めない
飲めないと思いますけどね
アルコールの中に入れるものっていうのは
お酒を飲まない インドでも作れません
で 皆様にはわかりませんですけど
だから皆様の場合は意識は大事だから
酒を通しても やっぱり一石一石二鳥でやりましょうと思ったら酒飲んでることにもなるし
酒を飲みたいし 体の健康を維持したいし
ですから まあ一石二鳥で養命酒にしようと思ったら
もうちゃんと酒飲んだことになります
体が本当に病気で この病気治すためには養命酒しか薬はないというならば
もう酒飲んでるわけじゃないんですね
病気治して治そうとしているんだから
薬で扱うんですね で 薬の量っていうのは酒の機能は代替しないんですね
酒が機能すると もう薬の機能はないんです
そこまでお釈迦様はよく知ってるんです
例えば養命酒にしても
酔うところまで飲むと
養命酒にある薬成分は体で機能しないんですよ
役に立たない 役に立たないんで
ただ酔って終わっちゃうんです
で 薬として体を健康にする分だけ量だけ飲むと
飲むと体が酒は認識しないんです
ただあちこちで吸収しちゃって
もう酒と言ったって まあすぐ吸収して分解するものだから
簡単に分解してしまっちゃう
で 残るのは薬成分が残ってるんですね
だから体としては薬として認識する
だからどこにいくんですか？肝臓
そこら辺でいって分析できないものが分解できないものが血液に入って酒になって酔うでしょ
それでちょっと量飲まないと
ほんのちょっと飲んだらすぐ肝臓がもうバラしちゃって
糖にしてしまっちゃうんですね
糖にしてあちこち保管しておくんだからね
ですから その場合は体がこれを酒やとわからないんですね
そこでお坊さんたちにも病気になったところで
インドのこのある一種類の薬はもう発酵しますから
その時でも酒持ってきて酒に薬入れることは絶対そういう方法はないんです
薬いっぱい作って それに水やらを入れて
もう大量に あの 何て言いますか
黒蜜やらね 入れるんですね
それで入れて埋めておくと
大量で言ったらそれほどないんですけど
だから飲んでもものすごい甘いだけ
だからこの酒の香りがない
味はしない という薬だったら
医者に推薦すると それは飲んでもいいんですね
出家も 酒の成分入ってるんだけど
香りと味はない ということをね
もし医者が推薦しても
酒の香りはブンブンするんだったら
もうそれはやめなさいと
で 例えば筋肉痛というかね
体が痛くてとかね それはこういう酒でマッサージすればいいんじゃないかという薬方法あっても
比丘にはそれも禁止  [笑い]酒のマッサージ
お釈迦様はよく知ってるんだから
酒っていうのは皮膚からも入ります
で 酔うんです 鼻からも入ります
それで酔うんです だから香りも嗅いではいけないんです
それは出家の世界で 関係ないんです
そんな話聞いたって 私に
皆様には関係ないことでね
言いたいのは我々に目を開けるなよとね
我々の猿真似をしてしてみてうまくいかないんだからと言って
我々にガチャガチャガチャガチャ愚痴やら文句やら言ってくるなよ
だからちゃんと世界は別々であるということを理解しておけばね
もううまくいくでしょうに
だからこのわざとこの脱線したら
まあまあ仏教 まあ困りますけどね
そこら辺全部気をつけて
ちゃんと仏教はもう問題を起こさないようにきちんと教えているんです
在家には在家の生活はちゃんとそれを教えてあって
出家には出家の生活ということですね
でも在家の人々にも酒は飲むなよとちゃんと禁止はしてあります
それぐらいのことで 読経集の場合でもね
どんな気分で読んでいるかっていうことは
それはヒロミさんに聞いたって言ってくれないでしょうね
お酒はあのインドとかね
スリランカとか南だとね
やっぱり刺激が強いというか
そういうようなこともあれもありませんか？っていうのは逆に日本でね
仏教語る時にはもうお寺っていうのはお酒を飲む場所と思って
田舎のお寺はほとんどもうお酒飲んでますからね
まあそれは長い間の習慣の結果であって
別にあの 体質 体質を計算して日本人やってるわけじゃないでしょうに
だからそういうものみんな私も何回もその同じ評論で聞いたことありますけど
学者やら研究者やらね
私はもう学者はいいんだけど
もう学者はもう嘘をつくのは平気でも
いい加減なことでいい加減なことを言うなよと言いたいところなんですけど
で 日本ではもう長い間の習慣で
それはお寺は酒飲む場所になっている
それは長い間の習慣でしょ
それはそれで あ これは習慣だよと認めた方が
私は客観的に正しいと思います
やっぱりインド人酒飲んだらものすごく攻撃激しくてと言ったっても
それは嘘じゃないんですよ
それだったら現代的に研究しなきゃ
人間をサンプルを取って
それをまるっきりやらないで
あまりにも偏見というか
差別思考なんですよ インド人の酒の飲みっぷりも知らないんだから
みんな 知らないで言うんだからね
冗談じゃあいつらの酒飲み方っていうの
我々アジアから見れば
日本人の酒飲み方見たらね
かなりできてるんではないかと
立派で 飲めないんですよ
みんな酒は結局は それにスリランカ人にでも酒飲む人を見たら
まあウィスキー瓶一つ開けて二人呼んでみてください 4
分の3一人で飲みますよ
日本人がほんのちょっと飲んでもうもう酔っ払っているんですけど
向こうは全然平気で 事実はそういうことなんですね
それで私は留学生かくにんの時は大学の教師たちも何人かいたんだから
もう酒飲むは飲むもう切りがないんですよ
学校から帰るとものすごい大きいウィスキー瓶があるんですよ
何リットルかな わからない
すごい なんか樽みたいで
あれ一つ持ってくるんですよ
来たら 2日で 3日で終わる
何のことない 水で割る氷で全然ない
で 日本人も一緒に酒飲んで飲みに来るんだけど
みんなバタバタ倒れる
でもスリランカ連中がもう酒飲んで
また踊って遊んでギャーギャーいろんなことを喋ったり
それでもものすごい頭が面積で回転したりとか
で 料理も作ったり もうご飯も食べて
また人々も最終電車にも運んであげたりまでして
あるいは行かなかったらもう 2時 3
時までまたやって もう日本人は次の日はもう出て行かない
向こうは学校に行くんです
朝 それでインド人もだからスリランカ人だけインド人も見てましたし
イスラム酒飲んではいけないパキスタン人も知ってるし
飲むというともう もう
だからわしはもう品が悪いんだと
日本人というのはすごく声でかっこよくて品格よく
ほんのちょっとはどうもどうもとかなんとか言って
で ほんのちょっとだけでしょうに
それで酔っ払って倒れて
もうもうもうもう タクシーに乗っちゃったら
何か場所を言うと それもう北海道の場所を行ったりとかね
九州のどこか行ったりとかね
運転手さんも困ったりとかね
だからまあそう 実はそれ私も今いい加減なことを言いましたけど
本当に体質的に誰かっていうことは研究しなきゃわからんことでしょうし
で 日本人の体質は日本では研究されてますけど
それから見てもあんまり酒は合わないんですよ
日本人にも それと仏教は関係ないんだからね
日本人でも酒はいくら飲んだっても平気な人もいるし
全く一滴も飲まない人もいるしね
そんなのはもう遺伝的に
まあいろいろ出来具合もありますからね
それはわからない でも酒っていうのはものすごい
やっぱりインドの社会
スリランカやらそういう社会を見ると
本当に嫌なものなんですね
あれは もう家を売ってでも飲むやつは読むんですよ
だからこの体に悪い すごいインパクトだったらみんなやめるんですよ
飲んでもうすごいなんか大変なことになったとかなんだったら
簡単にやめますからね
それはないんですよ だからすごいたちが悪いんですね
だからもう厳しく戒律ででももう抑えられているんですよ
だからそれは社会的なことで
ブッダがお釈迦様が酒を飲まないと言っているのは
もう智慧が錯乱するんだからなんです
智慧と知識が 智慧の育てる世界だから
もうもってのほかなんですよ
もう絶対もう使ってはいかんということなんですね
厳密に知識やら脳細胞育てていこうと思っているところで酒導入したらどうなるんですかね
だから仏教においてはもうもう無条件で禁止っていうことになるものなんですね
まあ罪とかなんとかという場合はね
まあ罪と言えば無常の方がすごい罪は多いし
で 罪よりはもうお前ものすごい損するんだよ
例えば脳細胞壊れたらその一生終わりでしょ？もう修行も何もできんでしょ
たとえ天才で生まれても
脳細胞の中にある穴なんか大きくなっちゃったらね
穴４つありますからね
ピーマンと言ってもやっぱり脳には穴がありますけどね
で そこはちょっと大きくなっちゃうとね
細胞に圧力をすごくかけちゃうし
で そこでこのひずみやらね
そういういろいろ溝やらいっぱいできてこないと
面積いっぱい必要でしょうね
脳にはね 頭いいって人の場合
脳の面積が大きいんですね
脳の量はみんな同じですけどね
でもグニャグニャになっちゃって面積が大きくなるんで
そうすると細胞が平らになって使っているでしょうし
そこで酒飲んで この脳の中にある四つの穴がね
液体がありますね そこはどんどん膨らませちゃうでしょう
そうすると圧力が上がっちゃって
やっぱり面積が少なくなっちゃうんですね
そこを固定しちゃうと
もう終わり 戻れませんしね
ですから もし酒飲んで知識は悪くなってしまっちゃえば
もう後戻りはないんだから
せっかく人間に生まれて全てパーになっちゃったんだからね
そういうわけで もうものすごいもったいないことをしたということになるんですね
だから人を殺したら それは明らかな罪で
嘘を言ったら明らかな罪で
だからこの見方が私もあまりわからないんですよ
酒飲んだらどんな地獄に落ちるかとかね
それははっきりしてないんですよ
例えば泥棒したり よく知らない行為したりすると
もうあんたは輪廻ではこういうこういう風になるんだよということは
たまたま若い時言ってますけど
酔っ払いはどうしますかという場合はそれほど
だからはっきり定めることもできませんね
結局は大損したことは確かなんですね
全て失ったと 人間としてはね
まあ成長することも 知識人になることも
悟る可能性も もう瞑想していくらかね
進んでいくことも失っちゃうんです
だから智慧は失っちゃうんですね
だから まあ一応酒飲む人は動物の世界に生まれ変わっちゃいますけどね
智慧がなくても生きていられるということで
人間で生まれてもすごくこの知識がない人間としてなってしまうという話はありますけどね
まあそれはそれで ヒンドゥー教ではそんなに酒にはね
断ってないみたい キリスト教も酒には断ってないしね
イスラム教は激しく断ってますね
でも麻薬はOK なぜかというと
コーランで書いてないんだからですね
だからそういうへ理屈でね
やっぱりコーランというのもいい加減なもので
大したものではないんだからね
そこ厳密に計算してるわけじゃないし
厳密に考えて喋ってるわけじゃないし
うーん まあ日本では仏教よりも日本の神道はね
まあ酒を聖なるものとして扱っていて
だから神道がある世界に仏教が入り込んじゃったんだからね
まあ仏教も酒と一緒になっただけのことではないかなと思いますけど
だからみんなもうちゃんと勉強するんだとすぐわかるもんですよ
だから私にいつも色々文句言ったってもね
そんな酒に断っても 日本の仏教はもう酒で一緒で言ったって別に私は逆に言いたいのは
あんた方本当にそうですかと
もっと勉強しなさいと
そうじゃなくて 元々日本は神道の国で
今も日本は神道の国 土着宗教それだから
だからその器に入りますからね
他宗教っていうのは この外から来る宗教っていうのは
ですから 当然宗教儀式はいくつか同じものを使わないとコミュニケーション取れないんですよ
ですから もう仏教も神道の世界でやっている宗教儀式は全部ではなくて
いくつか使って もう自分たちも一つの宗教だと一般人にアピールするんですよ
それがもうごく宗教歴史の中でごく普遍的
普通に起こる当たり前の出来事なんですね
そこでなんとなく聖なる品物の一つとして酒も入ってしまっただけで
それで個人個人 人間というのは酒飲みたくてたまらんもん
いわゆる罪を犯したくてたまらんと
それは坊主にしたって同じことだから
やっぱり罪を犯す すごい刺激的で気持ちはよろしいし
戒律守るとなんかつまらないってことは
これはもう人間だからね
当たり前のことで それでお坊さんたちもズルズルズルすると
まあ飲むことになったんじゃないかなと
だから神に捧げるものって酒でしょ
いわゆる人間にとってみれば
すごい尊いものを差し上げると
それで仏教徒になったら
ではお釈迦様 ブッダにももう尊いものを差し上げようと思ったら
この習慣として じゃあ酒ということになるんですね
それでどんどん時間が経っていくと
お釈迦様に差し上げるものはなんで我々が飲んで悪いかということ
それは別にごく自然な的な思考の流れなんです
例えば昨日電車で質問されちゃったんだけど
何で線香をなんとか使い
それは瞑想なんかで何かどういうことに使いますか？でも全然そんなこと何でもないんだと
何で線香を立てたりするかというと
遠い昔 尊い方々に王様やらそういう貴族の人々やら
そういう色々な人々に前で花のお飾りをして
こちらで代わりのね 香水を立てて
こうなんて言ったら お香を立てたりして
そこで音楽を奏でたりとかね
こちらで踊り子たちを踊ったりとかね
そうやって偉い人をもう拝む
拝むじゃなくて 褒め称えるためにあらゆることをやるんです
だから偉い人は偉いと尊敬するために人間何やってるかという
そんなことをやってますから
お釈迦様に対してお花を差し上げましょうということになっただけのことなんです
ではお香を立てましょうと
どこにもブッダに対してお香を立てなさいとどこにも書いてないんですよ
それは人間の気持ちなんですね
お釈迦様が涅槃に入るときは
あらゆるところからもうみんな無茶苦茶花を持ってきて
花を持ってきて もうお供えするんですね
礼をするんですね それは人間の気持ちであって
同じく日本の場合はもう酒をちょっと神様に差し上げることはもう大変なありがたいことで
だからありがたい だから仏教徒だったらもう同じことに
ではもう酒をお供えしましょうということになったんじゃないんでしょうかと思いますけどね
私は別に日本の社会は勉強したわけじゃないんだから
あくまでも推測で喋ってるんです
それであの酒と日本仏教はもう一体になってしまった
これは大乗仏教の特色であるならば
台湾のお坊さんたちもずっと酒飲んで酔っ払ってるはずなんですね
でも 日本仏教の大本である中国仏教では酒は飲まないし
で 韓国では飲むみたいですけど
それではみんなではなくて
まあどんどんどんどん
まあまあ韓国はもう仏教はないんだから
まあまあ 90% キリスト教になってますからね
それはもう私はもう15年もっと前に韓国
韓国人に行ったんですよ
あんた方は頑張らなきゃ
見てみろと もう笑われたんだけどね
それはまあ やっぱりまあそんなことなんですね
だからまあ それは大切なことではなくて
長い間の まあ習慣の結果なんです
でも瞑想はまあするならば
やっぱり酒で酔っ払ってはできませんよね
それは決めてますね  [紙の音]